in hannover ist das bauamt komplett
eingerüstet seit fast sieben jahren
dafür hat die stadt bislang stolze 500
4000 euro miete gezahlt weil das bauamt
mit der sanierung des bauamtes nicht in
die gänge kommt wird das teure
stahlgerippe auch so schnell nicht
wieder verschwinden halte ich nicht für
die beste geben wie eine posse in sich
finde ich das ausgerechnet dass bauern
in seinem haus gearbeitet was
sanierungsbedürftig ist es kann nicht
sein dass jahrelang ehrung steht und zu
wessen zierte soll das heim zu erzielte
das stadt erreicht dass eine auf jeden
fall nicht gebaut in den 1950 er jahren
nagt der zahn der zeit schon heftig an
der bauverwaltung deshalb will die stadt
das gebäude schon seit jahren sanieren
weil 2013 einige fassadenteile abfallen
wird ein bauzaun rund um die behörde
aufgestellt 2014 folgen weitere
untersuchungen
danach wird zur sicherung das gebäude
komplett eingerüstet kosten dafür
73000 euro pro jahr in sachen sanierung
aber herrscht dornröschenschlaf
obwohl auch beim brandschutz und
barrierefreiheit handlungsbedarf besteht
das schiebt einer dem anderen die
verantwortung zu und jahre gehen ins
land
ich finde das vorgehen so sind frei das
angefangene projekt muss auch zu ende
gebracht werden nicht einfach nur die
verzögerung bezahlt werden im
benachbarten rathaus kann man die
aufregung nicht verstehen
man habe andere projekte vorziehen
müssen wann die sanierung des bauamts
endlich losgeht kann uns niemand sagen
schriftlich heißt es derzeit sind die
planungen unterbrochen bei freigabe der
weiteren planung werden circa zwei jahre
vorlaufzeit bis zu einem möglichen
baubeginn benötigt in hannover fürchten
sie dass das teure baugerüst gar nicht
mehr verschwindet das peinliche an der
ganzen sache ist eben dass da die
experten sitzen die für andere leute ein
halbes jahr an der antragsfrist haben
wenn die ihn
der stall an ihrer garage anbauen wollen
aber selber kriegen sie einen eigenen
laden nicht im griff was macht sauber so
was das ist das ist einfach schlechte
planung und und geld rausschmeißen wo es
nicht nötig ist
obwohl die sanierung des bauamtes auf
den sankt nimmerleinstag verschoben ist
lohne sich der kauf eines eigenen
gerüsts nicht so die stadt
hoffentlich hat man sich da im rathaus
nicht verrechnet